in our hyper-partisan political
environment it's easy to get stuck in
our own talking points and refuse to
listen to the arguments of the other
side especially on hot-button social
issues on hot-button civil rights issues
on constitutional issues like the second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
but this is a republic we've got to
learn to live together we've got to
learn to compromise sometimes and i have
just heard a gun control proposal care
of indianapolis colts gm chris ballard
that i think i might actually be willing
to get behind
it's a shame
you know highland park uvalde greenwood
buffalo
i mean when is it you know when do we
what is some common sense coming to play
and when does this end
when do when do our elected officials
actually do something about it instead
of their own political gain
and both sides of the both sides
both sides are
completely wrong
i'm not anti-gun
but i'm anti-military style weapons that
it blows my mind away that an 18 year
old kid can walk in
and buy an
ak-15 automatic weapon
that makes no sense
zero
that makes no sense zero fact check true
i agree with that conclusion there you
know they said that america was too far
gone for bipartisanship well there it is
i
i support what this man is proposing i'm
michael knowles a strong supporter of
the second amendment a lifetime member
of the nra officially endorsed this
proposal to ban all
ak-15 automatic rifles no more
i have never seen a gun control bill
more sensible than this one i've never
heard a gun control advocate be more
articulate than this colt's general
manager
and there has never been a more serious
and beneficial piece of anti-gun
legislation let the era of mutual
understanding commence i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday was not for many of
you you sent me some very nice comments
too but my absolute favorite comment was
from an obstetrician who said mr dolls
here is your baby boy very uh very nice
of all of you to send in nice notes as
well uh yes my second child was born
yesterday i was it's been great i've
been awake for uh with intermittent bits
of closing my eyes for about
36 or 48 hours now and i said i am not
missing my show today no sir
we have got a responsibility
not just to the listeners but to america
so immediately after my show i will be
going back to the hospital and spending
the rest of the day with my cute little
newborn baby boy but thank you to all of
you for the the very fine comments when
you when you see your child for the
first time it makes you think not just
about life
but about death what is going to happen
to these sweet little babies when
someday you are no longer with us how
will you prepare yourself well the
answer my friends
is epic will right now go to
epicwill.com
use code knowles for all you adventurous
spirits out there did you know here's a
fun fact a hundred percent of people who
skydive will die
100
100 of people who breathe
also will die whatever you do however
you try to avoid it
you will die no one here gets out alive
and you got to make sure that you take
care of your sweet little beautiful
babies your kids you got to make sure
you take care of the people who love you
and you gotta make those important
decisions about what's gonna happen to
you and all your stuff and to your
family so that your loved ones aren't
stuck in a lurch when you finally kick
the bucket a will is not even primarily
about you it's about all those loved
ones and the hard decisions they are
going to face
when something happens to you i won't
even say if because it is inevitable my
friends sorry that this is a little bit
of a downer but that's how it goes
that's why you got to go to epic will
get your whole will sorted out you can
do it it's very very quick it's
extremely inexpensive if you go to epic
will use promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s
you will save 10 on epic will's complete
will package they'll set you up with a
will in as little as five minutes it's
it's about 119
to secure your family's future
unbelievable deal without a will
you're going to hand your stuff and your
money over to people who don't like you
very much i'm talking about the
government talking about all sorts of
bad folks don't do it go to epicwill.com
use code knowles today
speaking of life and death that this gun
control proposal from the colts gm is
it's so beautiful because it it
perfectly typifies
all of the anti-gun proposals that you
hear from the left that guy obviously
doesn't know anything about politics he
doesn't know anything about anything
maybe he knows a little bit about sports
but even that i'm not so sure and so he
goes out and he pontificates about
guns and all he does is repeat the same
meaningless talking points that he's
heard on cnn or from some late night
mainstream comedian stephen colbert or
something like that and he just recites
them completely mindlessly like a
non-playing character in this video game
called america and and
he he never even stops to examine what
they might mean so he says we you know
look i i'm not anti-gun
i'm
anti-military kind of
gun what do we mean by a military gun
you know the kind of guns that are used
for assaults
you know unlike those really nice warm
fuzzy comfy guns you know they're really
the guns that are just meant to hug you
and gently caress your forehead and
whisper sweet nothings and tell you
everything's gonna be okay not like
those assault guns
so he draws this distinction that
doesn't exist
all guns can be used for military
purpose all guns are intended not just
to assault people but to kill people
that's the point of a gun is to kill
people and kill them dead he then refers
to the ak-15 which does not exist the
gun to which i suspect he is referring
is the ar-15 he says this is an
automatic weapon the ar-15 is not an
automatic weapon you all know all of
this i'm not telling you anything that
you don't know but chris ballard over at
the colts doesn't know any of this and
it's not just him it's not just the
no-nothings who who spout off their
pre-packaged talking points that have
entered their minds unawares and escape
their mouths without any critical
thought passing in the meantime it's
even the people who are writing this
kind of legislation the people at the
very tippy top elected democrats very
often
demonstrate their own ignorance on
issues like guns and they remind us how
insane it is that this civil right this
constitutional right a basic right to
protect yourself
is being threatened and regulated by
people who know absolutely nothing about
what they are regulating and they go
even further by the way so you heard
there
chris ballard he says i'm not against
guns i'm just against the crazy radical
why does a kid get without without any
training he gets to go in and get a gun
and this is so he's saying i'm again i'm
for responsible gun ownership but i'm
against irresponsible gun ownership and
then nancy pelosi comes out
and she comes out against responsible
gun ownership as well
when i talk about it on the floor this
afternoon i'm going to show
i want to show a presentation of what
some
totally irresponsible people are putting
out there
about little children toddlers
learning how to use an assault weapon
smaller assault weapons but a gun like
mommy and daddy small
assault weapons but getting their
muscles ready to be able to use it
is that sick
is that sick so i don't know what guns
she's referring to maybe that's what the
ak-15 is maybe chris ballard and nancy
pelosi know something we don't know i
have never seen
an ar-15 in a toddler size i i've never
seen that at the gun store i'm not sure
do they miniaturize the ammo two they
take the two two three and they just
shrink it down i'm not i'm not so sure
are th is she just referring to a little
toy gun yeah kids have little toy guns i
had little toy guns my children will
have little toy guns they'll be squirt
guns maybe a nerf gun we all have them
is that what she's saying is so
irresponsible or no is she saying it's
irresponsible that parents are
familiarizing their children with
guns
because if that's what she's saying then
it's completely the opposite isn't it
the irresponsible thing to do if you're
a gun owner and you have guns in your
home
is to not tell your kids anything about
it that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do you just kind of leave them
out or you even hide them but you never
familiarize your kids with them and so
one day your kids are going to find them
they're not going to know what to do and
god forbid something terrible could
happen that's that's irresponsible gun
ownership responsible gun ownership
especially if you have a family is
familiarizing your kids with these
weapons showing them
how to hold them how not to hold them
not to use them you know if mommy and
daddy aren't around and various never
don't load the gun don't do this this is
what they do this that
that's the most responsible gun
ownership that there can be
you're saying this is a this is a weapon
we're going to we're going to exercise
this right in our home but we're going
to be very very careful this is a
powerful thing so don't don't get out of
control here
that what what pelosi is showing us is
that she's not just against
irresponsible gun ownership
she and the democrats are against
responsible gun ownership as well in
fact they're especially against
responsible gun ownership because all
the gang bangers in chicago those guys
get off the hook
we when when we talk about the gangsters
who are committing the actual gun
related crimes in chicago in new york in
los angeles those are the people that we
are told need to be let off the hook
society has failed them we've got an
over-incarceration problem we've got to
let them back on the street all those
george soros-backed da's all those those
extreme liberal da's that are even now
being recalled in liberal cities they're
saying oh let those people with their
guns back onto the street the people
they're going after are you
they're going after responsible gun
owners who don't commit crimes who
follow the law they're trying to take
away your weapons they're trying to take
away your ak-15s okay they're trying to
take away
your rifles that are not used that are
statistically used in virtually no
homicides per year
that's what they're after because
in in many ways the democrats support a
kind of tactical lawlessness this is
sometimes called anarcho-tyranny
and it's that the democrats encourage a
certain kind of chaos and social
disorder so that they can take more
power and claim a greater crisis and use
that crisis for a political end never
let a crisis go to waste this is why the
libs will encourage blm rioters to burn
down half the country
they do it even if it's going to hurt
some of their storefronts
even if it's going to damage some of
their cities it permits them
to take more power that's what we're
seeing here when you see these gun
control bills every single one in recent
decades they go up it's not to stop blm
from tyrannizing your city it's not to
stop antifa it's not even to stop mass
shootings none of the gun control laws
that have been proposed in recent years
would have stopped the mass shootings
there's a very famous fact check from
the washington post on this very point
just six or seven years ago but the the
point still holds up today the point of
all of these gun laws is to take the
guns away from you
i've had kids on the mind recently i
don't know what it is
when and when i think about the future
of our country and the future for our
kids think about prageru you kids right
now head on over to prageru kids.com if
you like me have kids on the mind have
you seen what your kids are watching on
tv what they're learning in school
marxism socialism critical race theory
they're starting kids as young as
kindergarten as young as preschool on
this stuff
disney's recent directives to degender
children
executives quote not-so-secret gay
agenda to push the non-binary pan-sexual
ideologies into kids movies
america's system of educating our kids
has been completely hijacked by the left
and guess what
parents and upstanding educators are
fighting back with prageru kids
prageru kids is here to help from
animated shows illustrated books and
digital magazines prageru kids offers
entertaining and educational content to
equip families to save their kids and
the future of america you look in a
classroom it's like a crystal ball about
the future of your country okay so get
tons of resources to watch at home and
in classrooms by downloading the prageru
app to your smart tv and devices go to
prageru kids.com right now
enjoy all their great content and
support prageru in their efforts to get
america back on track subscribe now
don't miss fragrance incredible free
kids content you know i myself am the
prager you host i host the book club
over there lots of five minute videos
the kids stuff is fabulous go to prageru
pragerukids.com
today
speaking of bad liberal policies
inflation is at 40-year highs everything
is more expensive that is harmful to
everybody but everybody except the
federal government actually inflation is
very good for the federal government
because the united states government
owns an insane amount of debt and when
inflation is very high then that debt
is is much less expensive to carry
because the dollar just isn't worth the
same amount that it was
a year ago or six months ago or even a
few months ago so the only people who
benefit actually from high inflation are
our governments and people who hold huge
amounts of debt but
for the rest of us it's it's really
really painful at the gas pump at the
grocery store and so how are democrats
going to combat this kind of inflation
are they going to
produce more domestic energy that would
be the easiest thing to do to combat
inflation inflation is being driven by
high energy prices joe biden shut down
new pipelines in america and he shut
down new oil and gas leases so the
easiest thing you could do would be to
green light more american energy that
would instantly bring down inflation
joe biden refuses to do that one of the
excuses the democrats use is they say
well it would take a year
or a year and a half to get up and
running yeah okay joe biden's been in
office for more than a year and a half
if he had done this a year and a half
ago we wouldn't be in this mess right
now so are they going to do that no
they're not going to increase energy
are they going to i don't know are there
there's nothing really you can do now
about the war in ukraine which joe biden
almost single-handedly caused in in the
words of ukraine president vladimir
zelinsky by green lighting russia's oil
pipeline and literally inviting putin to
invade when he said if if the russians
invade part of ukraine as a minor
incursion we won't do anything about it
so that has driven energy prices through
the roof that's that's a really big
problem what else there's there are lots
of things
that the
what could the democrats do stop just
printing money and giving it to
everybody that would be another way to
to stop inflation
no they're not going to do any of that
they're going to pass the inflation
reduction act of 2022. that sounds good
i want to reduce inflation so there's a
study that was just taken
uh this was taken by uh penn wharton so
this is probably the most prestigious
business school in the country according
to penn wharton
the inflation reject reduction act of
2022
may actually very likely
increase inflation over the next two
years you leave it to the democrats it
does exactly
the opposite of what it says it will do
according to this study
inflation could rise by 0.05 percent
over the next two years so this is this
is marginal
right it we're not saying this is
definitely going to happen it's
statistically not very significant but
it is kind of kind of funny kind of
ironic that inflation would be going in
the opposite direction
you could then later on get a marginal
drop by the late 2020s in inflation
but it's just not it's not not going to
achieve
anything near what we're being told it
will
what does the inflation reduction act do
pretty much it just raises taxes and
spends money on environmentalism on the
green agenda
that's that's what it does
it it is just
it is just like every other democrat
spending bill they just happened to
title this one the inflation reduction
act
the whatever you care about now act of
2022 but oh it's just a regular democrat
bill hiking taxes on the people they
don't like very much and
spending more money on the green agenda
this is the democrats mo this is what
they do
the democrats are responsible for
inflation republicans share a little bit
of blame but not very much they share a
little bit of blame because the
republicans some of the republicans went
along with shutting the country down and
shutting the country down did screw up
supply chains and did screw up the order
of the economy and demand such that when
demand when the economy reopened and
demand spiked that did
contribute to inflation so republicans
have a little bit of the blame here but
it's mostly democrats democrats were the
ones pushing for the lockdowns it was
fouchy it was biden it was all it was
rochelle wolenski it was all of the libs
pushing for the lockdowns it's the libs
who shut down american energy
it's the libs who were trying to spend
gazillions of dollars and at the time
when the libs were trying to spend all
that money it was conservatives
conservatives like ted cruz like mike
lee even lindsey graham who is not
exactly the most rock-ribbed right-wing
person in the country they took to the
floor of the senate they said this is
going to drive inflation crazy do not do
this guys the libs pushed for it anyway
and that's that's what we get
that's what we get now we get lots of
inflation the lips create the problem
then they demand more power to fix the
problem and then when they have more
power they make the problem worse
and then what do they do they demand
more power to fix that problem rinse and
repeat that is what they do
this is
this is the course of democrat political
power on virtually any issue
and we're especially seeing it here
when it comes to inflation
now speaking of the green agenda
which is where so much of the the libs
focus goes to
sp and and part of that is because the
green agenda is just a catch-all you pay
off the companies that they like it
allows them to take a lot more power it
allows them to outsource a lot more of
american sovereignty to international
institutions like the united nations to
other other
international
trade treaties
so speaking of the green agenda al gore
has just compared
climate deniers you know you know those
people who deny the climate who just
they don't believe that we're walking
around in a kind of melee of oxygen and
nitrogen and you know those people who
just deny
they say there's no atmosphere they just
think they're floating around in a
vacuum somewhere they deny the climate
he says the people who deny the climate
by which he means people who are not
terrified of the sun monster and
catastrophic global warming
they're just like the cops in uvalde
this is time for all of us to step up
you know the climate deniers
are
really in some ways similar to all of
those almost 400 law enforcement
officers in uvalde texas
who were waiting outside an unlocked
door
while the
children were being mastered they heard
the screams they heard the gunshots and
nobody stepped forward and god blessed
those families who've suffered so much
and law enforcement officials told us
that's not typical of what
law enforcement usually does
and
confronted with this global emergency
what we're doing with our inaction and
failing to walk through the door and
stop the killing
is not typical of what we are capable of
as human beings we do have the solutions
and i think these extreme events that
are getting steadily worse and more
severe are really beginning to change
minds we have to have uh unity as a
nation to come together and stop making
this a political football it shouldn't
be a partisan issue you know it's
interesting
it's really interesting you know it's
really interesting uh is that
interesting is it because the point that
al gore just made
is that if you don't want to give 90
trillion dollars to aoc
then you're pretty much like cops who
let a psycho mass murder little children
you know when you really think about it
when you really think about it if you
don't give the democrats trillions and
trillions of dollars
to stop the sun monster from killing all
of you because of the predictions that
they've been making now for 50 years
which have not come true by the way and
which frequently have been reversed
decades later like the first time that
they started screaming about global
cooling and then they said oh actually
you know it's the opposite it's global
warming and then the warming kind of
cooled down for a little while and then
they said well whatever it's yeah it's
just changing it's changed give me 90
trillion dollars or we're all gonna die
if you're in any way skeptical of that
the same sort of people who told us
we're gonna have a population bomb in
1970 they said within 10 years we're
going to have mass famines everywhere
unless we
coerce poor people in the developing
world to sterilize themselves and kill
their children through abortion which
actually happened in india and china and
even so the world population doubled and
even so you know what happened were
fatter than ever malnutrition is at an
all-time low
if you are in any way skeptical
of the apocalyptic claims that people
like al gore make you're pretty much a
mass murderer of little children or at
the very least you're a coward who lets
the mass murderers get away with it
this shouldn't be political this
shouldn't now listen we can all agree my
i've got to work on my al gore it
shouldn't be political
what does that mean
you shouldn't this shouldn't be
political when democrats say it it's
just another way of saying
you shouldn't have a say in this thing
shouldn't be political
you're telling me that
changing the structure of our government
taking away a ton of people's money
taking away a ton of people's rights and
freedom and way of life
that's not political of course that's
political
that's the most political thing i've
ever heard of you're talking about the
way that society functions and the kind
of rights people can enjoy and the
traditions that people have and
political i mean it just means public
that's all it means you're talking about
public matters at the very least you're
saying this shouldn't be political it
it necessarily is political it by
definition is political what you really
mean is
you peasants
you hoi polloi with your incandescent
light bulbs and your gas guzzling cars
you disgusting peasants who don't even
drive teslas
you shouldn't have a say in it that's
what al gore
means that's what the democrats mean and
that's what they're fighting tooth and
nail to effect to bring about
their their version of not political is
i guess ultimately just that you don't
get a say
in politics it's not political it's the
private decisions of the liberal elites
who think that they are much much better
than you
you know speaking of ways to fight back
against the elites and the establishment
jeremy's razors is doing just that
this is the moment in the show where in
the years past i would have read you an
ad for harry's razors i would have said
hey hey you hey you millions of
listeners out there i love harry's go
out and buy a harry's razor
but i'm not going to do that because i
don't love harry's i
hate harry's if you don't know the story
harry is used to advertise on our shows
until
okay i'll take responsibility it was me
i i said on another show years prior
even before harry's even before harry's
joined as a sponsor i agreed with the
assessment
that boys are boys and girls or girls
and this was too much this is too much
for our sponsor
uh harry's which then pulled their ads
due to quote values misalignment well
we're not going to promote products that
hate your beliefs and hate you so we did
the only thing that makes sense we
launched our own razor company
jeremy's razors every jeremy's razor's
kit comes with a premium razor two sets
of blades shaving cream and aftershave
bomb it's a beautiful thing to behold
over 70 000 kits have already shipped so
instead of telling you that i'm a big
fan of harry's i'm here to tell you
about the thousands of ex harry's fans
and customers who have thrown their
razors in the trash like me i did that
too i used to use areas that threw in
the trash switched to jeremy's do not go
to harrys.com go to i hate harry's dot
com get your jeremy's razors founder's
kit
it's time to stop giving your money to
woke corporations that hate you give it
to jeremy instead we'll be right back
with a lot more
speaking of the dangers of man altering
his environment man playing god in
nature
kovid kovid's still going around
remember kovitt that thing that totally
definitely did not had no
relation to any experiments in any
laboratories definitely not any
laboratories in wuhan until okay maybe
it did and now even the who admits it
probably did so kova is still going
around and people are still catching it
even this is really weird even the
people who have gotten the vaccine are
still getting it this is even weirder
even the people who
have had the booster shot
and the extra booster shot and all the
booster shots they're still getting
coveted
president joe biden
president joe biden has tested positive
for kovitt this is not an outdated story
because i know i told you what a week
ago two weeks ago i said president biden
has tested positive recovery he's
quarantining and then president biden
came back well he first he made that
video of him looking all crazy and kooky
with his eyes were really really wide
and he had this really low voice and it
seemed like he was just being injected
with all sorts of uppers and he didn't
blink once in the video and it was
really really unsettling
and who knows what who knows what the
guy was on in that video but then okay
kovid passed he recovered he went back
to work now he's tested positive for
covet again
president biden
has said after
this is president biden's doctor after
testing negative on tuesday evening
wednesday morning thursday morning and
friday morning the president tested
positive late saturday morning
by antigen testing this in fact
represents rebound positivity whatever
that is guess he's got covet again and
he's quarantining again
i don't mean to laugh i hope president
biden makes a full recovery and remains
very very healthy or at least as healthy
as he has been
and thank goodness he got the shots you
know could you imagine how bad it would
be had he not gotten all the shots and
all the vaccines which are super duper
safe and effective and they're really
really good at preventing you from
catching kovid and from transmitting
covid oh sorry they changed that even
though they initially told us biden
wolenski and fauci all told us if you
get the shot you will not catch covid
you will not spread covet then they they
just gaslit all of us and said they
never really said that and then they
said the purpose of a vaccine is not to
stop you from getting it but it's
actually to stop you from having really
harsh symptoms and then biden had had
real symptoms anyway and he had to
quarantine and he obviously sounded and
looked terrible and then he recovered
and then he got it again
gosh he might have gotten covered three
times in two weeks had he not had the
shots right
he might have gotten it a fourth time in
two weeks had he not had the shots thank
goodness it was only two thank you
pfizer thank you moderna that's really
great speaking of plagues
speaking of plagues
monkey pox has become
it's become the anti-covid
it's become
the way that the libs forced us all to
live under covid which was very very
easily spread
and did not really pose major major
health risks to the vast majority of
people but it was still very very easy
to spray was so easy to spread that you
pretty much couldn't stop it from
spreading there was no measure that the
libs employed from the masks to the
lockdowns to the distance by six feet to
the shots to the boosters none of that
has actually worked to stop covid at all
not even in the slightest and yet they
made a shut down our lives for two years
then monkey pox
which can be a little bit more dangerous
but is not very easily spread there's
pretty much only one way to spread it
and it's not very pleasant at least in
the minds of the vast majority of people
monkey pox which is only i know this is
politically incorrect to say it's pretty
much only spread
at gay orgies not even at any orgy
though every orgy is in a certain sense
gay but specifically at male
homosexual
bath house style orgies that's where it
started the spread and that's where it
continues to spread
those we can't shut down now we can't we
can't even acknowledge it ned ryan who's
a conservative
activist
a sort of prominent conservative figure
he just went on a fox business show the
kennedy show
where it was him two other panelists and
the host kennedy and they were
discussing monkey pox and he suggested
maybe maybe people cool it with the gay
orgies for just a little bit
all three other people on screen
jump down his throat for it
as for monkey pox i think there's a
pretty good rule in life
uh don't attend gay orgies uh when you
look at the new england journal's report
of the fight how about anyone
reviewed ned come on man it's not about
gay how about not anywhere
go look at the new england journals
report that nbc news reported on on
friday in which of the 528 cases they
reviewed 95 percent
were between sex between men i think we
actually have to have a certain
conversation about where this is coming
from when i'm done brad you can talk
instead of going crazy and declaring a
national pandemic when 3 000 people have
it right now it's insane
i don't know man you don't have to be
gay to get monkey pox and
you don't have to be bigoted when you
talk about treating something that is
that easily spread it's not big yeah it
is this is science kennedy ninety-five
percent of the cases from the new energy
you know and i'm gonna let brad respond
okay that kind of i will use the term
bigoted language that makes it seem like
the only people that get this are from
one group of americans hey guess what
gay men also have friends and family
members and colleagues and this is not
just transmitted through sexual activity
so
everything that ned ryan said is right
virtually everyone who is catching
monkey pox is catching monkey pucks
because they had sex with a promiscuous
gay man
95 to 98 of the spread is among
dudes who have sex with other dudes the
the men who have sex with men community
as some people are calling it and then
some people around them are catching
monkey pox as well which raises a whole
lot of questions you know there were two
kids who caught monkey pox in households
with homosexual men
haven't heard anything about that sure
hope that's being investigated but i i
doubt that it is
what ned ryan said is right
and by the way if you want to
prevent people from catching monkey pox
if you if you care about the homosexuals
who are a risk of getting monkey pox
which is specifically homosexuals who
are getting frisky with lots and lots of
other homosexuals in promiscuous sex and
orgies
you would want this information to be
out there you'd want people to know the
risks right so he just
reads a news report from a left-wing
source about from a medical journal
and the three people on screen say
that's bigoted
those are hate facts
those are first you heard from brad
palumbo who is an lgbt activist and he's
i guess he's a liberty he would call
himself a libertarian and but he's very
very pro lgbt and he says oh ned you
can't say that it's annie orgies it's
don't say gay orgies but no it is
specifically it is gay orgies that
spreads monkey pox it's just a fact okay
it's just numbers 95 to 98 guys
okay
that's
no you can't say that and then
palumbo was far from the worst person on
that panel then it was the host kennedy
and the other guest whose name i believe
is marie harf
who called it bigoted
don't go to gay orgies is now considered
a bigoted statement
on on the right wing news channel on one
of what two or three right wing news
channels fox business is probably the
second most prominent right-wing news
chat allegedly right-wing news channel
and you can't say don't go to gay orgies
there are you knuckle dragging right far
right fascist bigoted drugledite how
dare you
gay orgies is what america was built on
so dare you discriminate against the gay
orgy community
these are the sorts of things that can't
be uttered now
it shows you the way that the overton
window has shifted
when when libs tell you oh no the
conservatives are on the rise the
conservatives have made so many cultural
gains in recent years just look at that
overton window look at the range of
acceptable discourse you can no longer
go on a an ostensibly right-wing news
network and say hey don't go to gay
orgies maybe if you don't want to catch
the gay orgy pox virus
and you you can't say that without being
smeared as a bigot
as some kind of hateful awful person
because you recite statistics that were
just published in a medical journal
that is the cultural shift yes i think
conservatives have great opportunities
right now we just overruled roe v wade
for goodness sakes this is great i think
the wind is at our sales
but the ground that we have to make up
is so insane the one that the liberals
are losing their minds over right now is
that conservatives might threaten this
new definition of marriage
the obergefell decision which redefined
marriage to include
same-sex unions
the idea that that would be the great
conservative cultural victory is insane
guys that that decision was made in 2015
that decision is seven years old
for all of human history up until 2015
everyone everywhere believed that
marriage had sexual difference at its
heart
that marriage was between a man and a
woman
the idea that we would return to that
and this would be the huge far right
fascistic
authoritarian return to 2014 are you
kidding me think about how much ground
we have lost
you realize how much ground we've lost
not even when you watch the far right
news channels it's when you watch the
news channels that are supposed to be
conservative you realize just how far
left the culture has become
this
this sort of monkey pox media reaction
is a true
lesson
in
in
political hierarchies who ranks above
whom whose rights get protected above
others during covet if you wanted to
visit your dying parents let's say they
were in a hospital or they were in a
nursing home they were just just kind of
aged you were not allowed to do that
when when your loved ones did die you
were not allowed to bury them you were
not allowed to have a funeral for them
for months or
years
george floyd was allowed to have four
funerals but you you were not allowed to
have funerals for your family members
you were not allowed to go to church you
were not allowed to go to work you were
not allowed to open your business in a
lot of places you were not allowed to do
much of anything
the pot dispensaries in california those
stayed open that was kind of weird
churches were closed but the pot
dispensaries were open okay that kind of
showed it gave you a little inkling huh
maybe this isn't just about what's safe
and what's healthy maybe this is about
the political preferences of the ruling
elite maybe this was about giving
special privileges to certain groups and
discriminating against other groups
and then monkey pox shows it for certain
we shut down the entire world for for
over two years
certainly you shut down the country
for a cough that was unpreventable
but you won't even shut down the gay
bath houses to stop the gay bathhouse
virus
you won't stop it you won't do it
you you're not even allowed to mention
it
even on
a conservative ostensibly conservative
news channel look what they're doing in
san francisco san francisco
which has problems
san francisco not the most orderly city
in the world
san francisco
is
hoping to host its annual sex festival
it's a sex festival specifically for gay
men
it's called the up your alley leather
fetish festival
i actually hadn't even read the name i
read that there was this festival i
hadn't read the name that is
totally gross it makes the story even
grosser than initially i thought it was
so they have this leather
gay festival in san francisco not
exactly a man bites dog story but
but the
festival's taking place
while there is a virus that is spreading
at gay orgies so you would think they
would shut it down right no
san francisco refuses to shut down this
event
the festival has been running since 1985
and they are not going to shut it down
even while a virus is spreading at the
gay orgies
it's not about what's safe it's not
about what's healthy it's about what do
we want to do
we we as a society well san francisco as
a society does not value church
does not value
small businesses does not value your
family having funerals for dead loved
ones does not value thanksgiving
celebrations does not value
high school graduations does not value
prom does not value any of the things
that got shut down for covid
but san francisco sure as hell values
gay leather orgies and so they're going
to shut down all the first ones they're
not going to shut down that last one and
this it gets right back to al gore's
point this should not be political
this should not why are we making this
issue of all your rights and your money
and your traditions in your country
where we're making this political
what this is about is what do we want to
do
what do we want to live with during
covid i
not only would have lived with
the risk of covet i not only would have
gone back to work and traveled and seen
my friends and gone to holidays and not
wearing the stupid mask and avoided all
the ridiculous measures that the libs
pushed on us but i actually did i did i
went back to work they forced us all to
work from home i lasted 24 to 4 to 36
hours and then i just went back to the
studio and it was pretty much just me
and jeremy at the studio for six months
at a time because i said i'm not doing
this i'm not going to work from home i'm
not going to quarantine i'm going to go
to all my holidays i'm going to go to
easter
easter sunday dinner and i'm going to
travel and i'm going to i'm just going
to live my life okay i made that choice
the political society said no we're not
going to do that
okay but i
i don't value gay orgies in that way
okay i don't value bath houses and
leather festivals and all that i don't
value that and i i don't think there's
any reason to tolerate that stuff period
but certainly not when there's the
spread of a virus specifically at these
places you have the political right
to say that
no matter what they tell you on whatever
news show even if it's on a technically
or ostensibly right-wing news show
you have the right to say that you have
the right to moral views you have the
right to political views you have the
right to social preferences you have the
right to an opinion on matters of public
health and the economy and the national
order you have a right to those things
and you can say no al gore i'm not going
to let you make me use those ugly
fluorescent light bulbs no san francisco
i'm not going to let you shut down my
church and no i'm not going to even let
you keep the bath houses and the leather
parties open okay we have
not just individual rights but there is
a higher sort of political right
those are political rights an individual
right is not not really political in the
sense that political is public it
involves other people and the founding
fathers talked about this and edmund
burke has talked about this and all the
great conservatives have talked about
how those that higher expression of our
liberty and our freedom is political
when we as a community say this is how
we want to live this is how we want to
flourish
speaking of the rainbow
a female soccer player has just been
sidelined for refusing to wear the
rainbow
her name is
jaylene daniels i'm not the
most up to date on female soccer news
she's the north carolina courage
defender and she was sidelined
for the team's friday soccer game
because she refused to wear an lgbt
rainbow on her jersey
she didn't agree with the rainbow she's
not down with the rainbow
and so she she didn't want to wear the
rainbow flag if you are a say christian
or or i would suspect a jew or a muslim
or if you have any kind of traditional
view of sexual ethics
you you can't wear the rainbow
so she says okay i'm not going to wear
the rainbow they said that's fine you
don't get to play you're going to be
discriminated against for your views on
these matters
the team said jaylene will not be
rostered tonight as she's made the
decision not to wear our pride jersey
while we're disappointed with her choice
we respect her right to set to make the
decision for herself we're excited to
celebrate the
lgbtqia plus community
with our fans players and staff tonight
and look forward to hosting our first
ever pride festival before knockoff
or before kickoff rather not knock off
would you
do you think it would be right to force
a jew or a muslim to wear a christmas
sweater
to work
let's say it's christmas time
and there's going to be a christmas
party at work whether we're talking
about they work at a soccer team or they
work at a an accounting firm do you
think it would be right to tell the jew
or the muslim hey you've got to wear the
christmas sweater in fact not just
you've got to wear you've got to wear a
nativity scene sweater
would that does that sit right to you
for
most people
in our liberal culture they would say no
that doesn't sit right i don't know i
don't think you should do that would be
wrong
it is
much more egregious
to force someone to wear the rainbow
because while the christmas season is
deeply deeply embedded in our culture
and still we you wouldn't say like hey
hey ben hey shapiro put the christmas
sweater on no one would say that
but
the pride flag the pride movement is a
relatively new movement extremely
radical in our culture it's opposed by
huge swaths of our culture
now you're saying well if you won't wear
my version my sexual preferences
my contradiction of traditional sexual
ethics on your sleeve literally on your
sleeve then you don't get to come to
work
then you
practically speaking don't have a job at
least while i'm forcing everyone to wear
this
it's obviously wrong you can tell that
it's wrong when you put it in those
terms but the culture doesn't see that
it's wrong it goes right back to that
seinfeld episode where everyone tries to
make kramer wear the little ribbon
remember during aids everyone wore a
ribbon you said you have to wear a
ribbon especially in new york put why
aren't you wearing the ribbons i don't
want to wear the ribbon i'm you know i
hope people recover from this disease
but i don't want to wear the ribbon
well you have to work you all have to do
it you have to show that you are on my
team
when it comes to this political matter
and if you don't they'll crush you
they'll absolutely crush you speaking of
religion
michelle nichols died she was an actress
she was in star trek she was a left-wing
activist and a widely beloved cultural
figure she died she was she was
quite aged so it's not you know it's not
like she flipped her corvette and it's
sad and tributes were pouring in for her
one of the the main tributes to her and
this became a trending phrase on social
media yesterday was rest in power
so i have basically nothing to say about
michelle nichols i haven't didn't follow
her career her acting or her activism
i'm not a trekkie so i
i don't don't wish her any ill she seems
like a lovely lady you know rest in
peace but rest in peace
i wouldn't say rest in power this phrase
keeps coming up whenever
usually whenever black people die
prominent black people die and then to
some degree left-wing activists more
broadly
you see this new phrase that's cropped
up in recent years rest in power which
is a silly and bizarre phrase it's
clearly a reaction against the
traditional phrase rest in peace from
the latin requiescat in pache
and it's it's a it's a kind of flipping
of that so don't rest in peace rest in
power
and a lot of the imagery from it comes
from the black power movement the fist
in the air which has become and even
more important left to symbol in recent
years we're going to have power
not just peace a politics that does not
seek a kind of reasoned and logical and
ultimately peaceful coexistence but a
politics that is just about the raw
pursuit of power and interest and
clobbering the other guy
all of this is is there
un simmering underneath this phrase rest
in power but rest in power is a really
stupid term
because
the only way that you will rest in power
after you die
is
if you go to heaven and get to behold
the baetic vision and get to be with our
lord and savior forever that i can
understand that you say that is a
position of power it is but it's only in
the sense that you are beholding
the the omnipotent power
you are wow you're in the vision of the
the true vision of the good the true and
the beautiful wow that's amazing
if rest in power is a rejection of that
view which i think it is i think it's a
rejection of christianity i think it's a
rejection of traditional culture i think
it is
a militant
a materialist kind of we're just going
to go ahead and get what we want and
that's our that's this the only things
that matter right in the here and now
and we're going to take power power
power then rest in power doesn't make
any sense
because according to that view when you
died you're not in power you become worm
food
you you go take a dirt nap and then bugs
eat you and then you turn to bones and
then your bones turn to dust and that's
it that's the end of the story that's
the least powerful position you could
possibly be in rest in power doesn't
make any sense outside of christianity
outside of a traditional culture against
which that phrase is rebelling
and there's you're seeing a lot of this
around the culture there's a story that
i really want to get to but i don't have
time today so i'll just tease it for you
an actress from the handmaid's tale is
really really upset
at discrimination that she has faced as
a woman but spoiler alert
the discrimination is not coming from
the right it's not coming from
christianity it's not coming from
tradition it's not coming from the
patriarchy the the
true discrimination that she's facing
is coming from the left as it almost
always is we'll get into that tomorrow
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show i'm going to go see my baby
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. on the matt wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show